ain't it she also gotta give birth to  all our babies because you know we gotta  have that Legacy but then she can't have  no stretch marks and she gotta lose that  baby weight in 30 days or less and and  then she got to do it while fighting  postpartum depression by herself because  we're gonna tell her she have an  attitude or something like that because  all we thinking about is we ain't got no  vagina in the last six weeks that she  got to take the hill  that ain't it then she can get older but  she can't look older  falling off like the list goes on but  just tell me something how many women do  you know that fit into that category  none  so who really got the unrealistic  expectations  sir it's so offensive it's like did you  did you have those unrealistic  expectations yeah like when your wife  was pregnant and your wife had those  children like are you just saying all  the things that you did while your wife  was going through all this I don't